[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben wir machen heute ultra
fluffige kinderriegelteilchen und zwar
wird es ein extrem fluffiger Hefeteig
einer der diese zusammenpresst und der
dann wieder aufgeht also bleibt
unbedingt bis zum Ende dran wenn ihr
diese Köstlichkeit nicht verpassen
möchtet und ich glaube es ist ganz
gefährlich denn es bleibt meistens nicht
bei einem Teilchen dass man dann ist
ich auch auf jeden Fall werden sie
unfassbar gut ich starte jetzt direkt
mit dem fluffigen Hefeteig das wird doch
ein echt einfacher Teig den der gelingt
euch immer ob ihr Backanfänger seid oder
nicht wichtig ist dass ihr vom Mehl dass
ihr dann vorher natürlich ab wiegt nicht
direkt alles mit rein geht in die
Schüssel also ich lasse immer so ein
bisschen extra hier
separat noch mal liegen damit es gleich
nach und nach dazu arbeiten kann wenn
ihr einmal alles rein geht und der zeigt
euch dann zu fest wird dann ist es
schwierig den wieder locker luftig zu
bekommen so dann mache ich jetzt eine
kleine Mulde und bzw was eigentlich
jetzt schon machen könnte das ist ja
noch einfacher gibt direkt schon Zucker
und Trockenhefe mit dazu sondern
verbindet sich
war noch ein bisschen was einfach mit
den sauberen Händen da rein da brauche
ich jetzt auch nicht nur ein extra
Schneebesen spannen uns ein bisschen
Geschirr heute so in die Mulde kommen
jetzt die flüssigen Zutaten und zwar
einmal Milch die ist schon lauwarm
einfach damit ich den g-prozess so ein
bisschen beschleunige so dann kommt dann
noch ein Ei mit dazu macht nicht nur was
mit der Farbe sondern auch mit der
Konsistenz und weil das ja ein fluffiger
Vanille Hefeteig sein soll gebt ihr das
noch Vanilleextrakt mit rein wenn ihr
das schon in Verbindung mit dem
Kinderriegel habt am Ende unfassbar gut
so da kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen Öl
mit rein ihr könnt Sonnenblumenöl oder
Rapsöl nehmen ich nehme einfach immer
das was ich gerade da habe und jetzt das
ganze mit den Händen verkneten wenn ihr
merkt ihr braucht noch ein bisschen Mehl
dann gibt ihr einfach was von dem Mehl
mit dazu
[Musik]
beim Hefeteig kneten mache ich immer
zwei Sachen einmal muss ich mitten im
Vorgang einmal kurz meine Hände waschen
damit ich wieder so ein gutes Gefühl in
den Händen habe und dann muss ich das
einmal noch so für eine Minute auf der
Arbeitsfläche kneten dann habe ich
wirklich ein gutes Gefühl und ich sage
ganz oft bei vielen Hefeteig Rezepten
dass sich der Teig so anfühlen muss wie
euer Ohrläppchen und genauso ist es ja
auch klebt auch nicht mehr in den Händen
aber wie ihr sehen könnt habe ich auch
nicht alles an mir gebraucht daher immer
vorsichtig mit dazugeben so jetzt muss
der Hefeteig einmal ruhen dann nehme ich
jetzt backtrennspray ich nehme jetzt
keinen extra Mehl weil sich das Mega
während der Ruhezeit auch noch mal den
Teig verarbeitet und ich dann Angst habe
dass er dann doch wieder trocken wird
und ich habe euch ja versprochen das ist
fluffiger Hefeteig ein bisschen
backtrennung drückbar und jetzt einmal
den Deckel drauf schön luftig 45 Minuten
dann gehen lassen und dann sehen wir uns
noch dann geht's wieder bis gleich
[Musik]
so die Uhrzeit ist um und jetzt wird der
Teig einmal durch oder in acht
gleichmäßig große Teile geteilt das
mache ich jetzt einfach nach Augenmaß
die können jetzt auch eine Waage holen
aber ich finde das eigentlich gar nicht
nötig also ich teile einmal mit meiner
Teigkarte hier in der Hälfte dann noch
mal jeweils in der Hälfte und dann noch
mal und dann haben wir acht Teile die
werden zu runden Kugeln geformt und dann
am besten noch mal 10 Minuten unter
einem sauberen Geschirrtuch einmal ruhen
lassen weil sie dann sich super
verarbeiten lassen und einfach sich
nicht mehr zusammenziehen die brauchen
dann noch mal diese 10 Minuten
Entspannung und dann können wir auch
schon weitermachen mit unserer
kinderriegelung
[Musik]
der Rest geht jetzt eigentlich sehr sehr
schnell in nehmt euch einen Teigling
erstmal mit dem Fingern leicht andrücken
und dann schnappt ihr euch einfach ein
ausrollstab und versucht es jetzt ich
würde jetzt nicht sagen komplett
dreieckig wie bei einem Croissant aber
versucht es so ein bisschen so zu machen
dass die beiden unteren Enden ein
bisschen in die Breite gehen und ihr so
eine kleine Spitze habt denn dann könnt
ihr das perfekt einrollen und als
kinderriegelung nehme ich jetzt die
Milch Joy cream denn die schmeckt
wirklich wie das weiße Innere von
Kinderriegel und ihr könnt euch jetzt
aussuchen ob ihr deutschen Kinderriegel
mit rein nimmt ich habe mir überlegt wir
bekommen ja acht ja acht Teilchen raus
mache ich viel mit und vier ohne und
wäre dann die volle Dröhnung Kinder
regeln möchte der macht die Milch Joy
cream drauf und wie gesagt
was für ein Top noch überlegt
tatsächlich gut vor finde ich auch ich
finde auch wenn man sich sowas können
dann braucht man nicht sagen oh hier
Speicher jetzt aber an den kalorienchen
nee nee das kommt da schön mit drauf
wenn die Seiten einmal einklappen
auf jeden Fall
dann einmal einrollen so den Ofen habe
ich heute übrigens mal nicht vorgeheizt
denn die kommen gleich in den nicht
vorgeheizten Ofen und während der dann
vorheizt können die noch mal in der
Wärme die da entsteht so ein bisschen
aufpuffen und noch mal noch lockerer
werden so ich mache jetzt hier weiter
und dann verrate ich gleich noch die
Backzeit und ich freue mich eigentlich
nur den ganzen Tag auf den Test mit dir
[Musik]
das nenne ich mal aufgegangene dicke
Teilchen oder also die sind schon echt
ganz gut aufgegangen
so diejenigen die jetzt kein
Kinderriegel innen drin haben die
bekommen ins Kinderriegel obendrauf und
dadurch dass es jetzt noch heiß ist er
hoffe ich mir ich weiß nicht ob es
klappt das versuchen wir jetzt mal hier
live ich hoffe mir dass das so schön
schmilzt und dann das wie so ein schöner
warmer kuscheliger Mantel noch auf die
teigteilchen kommen
es sollte wirklich wie so eine Decke so
fließend sein das soll das soll schon
Zeit ist rein aussehen und nicht wie
gewollt und nicht gekonnt und jetzt
lassen wir den Zauber geschehen und
hoffen dass es schmeckt so gut aussieht
aber ansonsten können wir auch gleich
ohne Test den Test machen
doch Kiki das sieht doch langsam ganz
gut aus oder
ganz oben
[Musik]
so stelle ich mir Milchbrötchen vom
Bäcker vor natürlich nicht so in der
Variante mit dem Kinderriegel ne aber
vom Teig her genauso stelle ich mir
damals damals waren die Milchbrötchen
mein Wecker auch irgendwie leckere habe
ich das Gefühl also der Teig ist richtig
fluffig auf jeden Fall komplett
ja haben wir jetzt eigentlich ne wir
haben eins erwischt ohne Kinderriegel
drin
und es schmeckt trotzdem eins zu eins
wie kinderriegeln also wer die volle
Dröhnung möchte soll sich auf jeden Fall
eins noch mit kinderregeln nehmen finde
ich bestimmt auch sehr lecker werde ich
gleich mal probieren aber das ist schon
Filmabend
Schokolade
richtiger netflix-abend ist sehr einfach
es sei denn man ist richtig hungrig und
sagt boah ich ist es egal also ich finde
immer noch es ist eine Kreuzung aus
Milchbrötchen wie man das früher vom
Bäcker kannte zusammen mit geschmolzenem
kinderregeln und das schmeckt einfach
unnormal gut
ich will einfach essen kannst
Essen
Pflanzen
heute einfach eine schöne Serie schauen
interessant tschüss
[Musik]